Welcome to the Council, on a European summit
day. The 27 heads of state and government
meet regularly here in Brussels. Today, they
have very serious matters to discuss: the
disaster in Japan, the crisis in Libya and
the Euro.
We are going to discuss the situation in Japan,
the situation of the nuclear plant in Fukushima
has showed me as a German Chancellor that
we cannot continue to act as before.
This is an important European Council, it
is important that the countries of Europe
show political will, ambition and unity.
The changes in a number of Arab countries
are of a historic dimension.
We must make sure we are all on the same page,
to define a clear line so that our action
can be in concert with that of the international
community.
The challenge now is that Europe as a whole
sends a very strong and convincing message
to the international markets that it is supporting
a stable euro and all Eurozone countries.
The 27 EU leaders are convened by the permanent
President of the European Council, Herman
Van Rompuy.
The European Council is comprised of the heads
of state and government of the 27 EU Member
States. I chair meetings of the European Council,
of which there are at least 4 each year, and
in practice 6 or 7. The European Council gives
the European Union its main impetus by providing
the broad lines and priorities for EU policies.
All European citizens are directly affected
by what is discussed around this table.
It is here that, at the start of the meeting,
the heads of state and government greet each
other. But they are not the only ones who
use this room… Other meetings of ministers
and meetings of the Council are also held
here, such as the Councils of Ministers of
Agriculture, Transport, the Environment and
Foreign Affairs, and each time, you have the
27 delegations plus the Presidency and the
Commission in attendance.
The Council is the main decision-making body,
although it does increasingly share this role
with the European Parliament. What is specific
to the Council is that here the Member States
cooperate and negotiate on a daily basis.
...This takes place at all levels: at the
highest level with the European Council, at
ministerial level with the Council of Ministers,
at the level of the ambassadors and the permanent
representatives committee, COREPER, and at
base level, i.e. that of the working groups
comprising national civil servants."
The ministers examine the Commission’s legislative
proposals and share the decisions with the
European Parliament in a large number of areas.
For all legislative work, the Ministers deliberate
in public, and their debates can be followed
live online.
I think it's right or proper that our emphasis
should be on renewable technologies and energy
efficiency technologies particularly.
The Ministers representing the Member States
are committed by the decisions that they take
together.
Good morning! Today we have a fisheries agenda,
we have to fix the quotas during the day,
and tomorrow we have to take action to prevent
illegal logging…
Today, the 27 ministers of economic affairs
have taken an important decision to stimulate
innovation in Europe: they have given the
greenlight to a simplified European patent
framework. This will considerably alleviate
administrative burdens on inventors.
The Hungarian Presidency is convinced that
greater cooperation on the European patent
will directly benefit 500 million Europeans
and all the businesses of Europeans, irrespective
of their nations
Once a month, the foreign ministers meet at
the Concil under the presidency of High Representative
Catherine Ashton.
The critical thing at the moment is the decision
that was taken under UN resolution 1973 to
do everything we can to support the people
on the ground, the people in Libya
The High Representative is also in charge
of the Union's external aid.
Europe can launch missions to manage crises
in troubled regions. At the moment, these
European ships are fighting piracy off the
coast of Somalia, and European soldiers are
training Somali troops to help restore order
in their country.
Europe's citizens are at the heart of the
Council's concerns. For the Ministers of Justice
and Home Affairs, that means helping citizens
to better enjoy one of the great advantages
of the European Union: freedom of movement.
As a recent popular movie reminds us; today,
thanks to Europe, there's no longer any need
to say: "nothing to declare".
It reminds me of when we were young. When
we crossed the border there was a customs
post. You had to declare any goods, show your
passport. When we were with our parents, there
was even some tension, when we went to France,
or the Netherlands, or Luxembourg, it was
a kind of adventure, we really had the impression
that we were leaving our country. Today, we're
in Europe, there are no more borders, you
just cross the border without realising it.
Psychologically speaking it's a completely
different world.
Now, from 7 countries which had decided to
abolish border controls, we now have 25…
This is an extension of the space of freedom
in Europe
Return to the European Council in March 2011.
A big decision has just been taken: The pact
for the Eurozone
We adopted the Euro Plus Pact. It will provide
a new quality of economic coordination.
We have put in place the economic government
of Europe.
I welcome the steps that the Eurozone has
taken today
We now have the pact for the Euro, in addition
to the 17 Euro member states, we have six
states in support. I think that very encouraging.
I think we have no other choice but to focus
on the economy; if we want to be taken seriously
in the world, we need to be strong economically.
If we want to protect our social model, we
need a strong economy in order to finance
it. In reality, our task is simple: greater
economic strength, so that we can also defend
our values in the world more effectively.